hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be continuing our series in the deep
blue vs. para match now last video we
went over Game one of the 1996 series in
which deep blue playing the white pieces
actually came out with a win now if you
do remember cuz Farah played the blue in
1996 actually ended up winning that
series they had a rematch in 1997 that
deep blue ended up winning with some
controversy so this series 1996 deep
blue goes up 1 0 initially and so in
game number two because Farah is now
playing the white pieces against deep
blue playing the black pieces now a few
things that I want you to keep in mind
while watching this is we're going to be
going over a lot of different variations
but Kasparov pretty much plays the
aggressive variation in whatever the
board is looking like it and he really
is going after deep blue he's not
playing passive he's really trying to be
as aggressive as impossible so being
down 1-0 you can really tell watching
this game that Kasparov you know came
out guns blazing really wanted to come
out with the W and make sure that he
even this up one to one also we'll be
talking about it more but as we move
into the in-game as you can see both
sides are going to have opposite sides
opposite colored bishops now this is
very very important if you haven't
watched the video already on different
colored bishops going into the endgame
def or recommend you watch that word
deck we're going to be talking about it
more in the video but just something to
keep in mind and then as we get into the
in game it's very interesting to watch
Kasparov play because he plays very
similar to a computer would especially a
supercomputer as far as his tactical
strategies really trying to every move
incrementally improve his position and
then at the end just being you know too
overwhelming for his opponent to to
actually deal with so few things to keep
in mind we'll go ahead and get into it
again conspire playing the white pieces
and deep blue playing the black pieces
Baro is actually going to start the game
with Knight to f3 very versatile move
gives him a lot of different options
depending on how black responds here
deep blue does respond with pawn
to d5 why it's going to continue d4 and
then after six why it's going to get
ready to fianchetto is Bishop here to g2
really i down on this light squares from
this a 8 all the way down to h1 try to
control these light squares in the
center of the board here black is now
going to play pawn to c5 again top-level
play players are really trying to
control this another board
counter-attack the center of the board
so that's just what deep blue is doing
playing pawn to c5 uh you know obviously
would kind of be a mistake here to take
here on c5 and then have deep blue play
you know Bishop takes on c5 really
gaining Center control of the board and
white no longer has any pawns in the
middle of the board so instead White's
going to continue and feeing kittymuz
Bishop to the King side as we talked
about before getting ready to castle on
the King side again anytime you're going
to develop your minor pieces to one side
typically that's where you're going to
castle and have King side safety from
here blacks going to continue with
knights and c6
obviously you want to be developing your
minor pieces towards the center of the
board and a lot of times you will see
the Knights come out before the bishops
you may have here developing night
before bishops so a lot of times their
Knights will be coming out to f3 C 3 C 6
and f6 and then the bishops will get
involved into the game now early on
again minor pieces are going to be
supporting the ponds and then later on
into the game the major pieces will be
supporting the minor pieces so from here
White's going to castle on the King side
again developing his minor pieces and
then getting his King to safety as soon
as Kasparov can life is going to play
Knight to f6
continuing with develop trying to
control the center of the board really
just trying to build up stuff and
support his pawns right now and why it's
going to play pawn to c4 trying to
counter-attack in the middle obviously
blacks playing pawn to c5 here trying to
attack this pawn here on d4 and that's
exactly what conspires trying to do he's
trying to counter-attack this pawn here
on d5 try to break up these light
squares in the middle of the board here
since he does have this bishop here on
g2 deep blue does have a few options as
far as how he could take if he wanted to
can always take with his night here on
d4 he could always take here on c4 he
could always take here on d4 but the
computer ops to take here on c4 and
Kasparov plays Knight to e5 now this is
actually a very common move in the open
catalana I'm not sure if you're too
familiar with the open Catalan again it
does play very similar to the reverse
grünfeld but whites not looking to gain
this material back right away although
he could if he wanted to try to gain
this material back right away but
instead because far I was looking to try
to gain center control be aggressive
knowing that this pawn is going to fall
later into the game as you're going to
see the knight can come here to a3 it's
going to be very difficult to hold on to
this pawn to c4 because this Knight is
again attacking this square here on b5
if the pawn ever wanted to come down to
b5 so just keep that in mind although he
is down a material he is gaining Center
control and he's going to get this
material back so again very common but
if you've never played the open cut
Allen this is going to be a common theme
that you're going to see from here
black's going to play Bishop to d7 again
it would kind of be a mistake for black
to allow Knight to come to c6 and then
you're going to have triple pawns on the
C file double pawns you can kind of get
away from that because you can see why
it's probably going to take one of those
pawns but triple pawns early on into the
game you typically want to avoid triple
pawns if you need to so blacks going to
play Bishop to d7 again developing his
pieces he does have the option to either
bring his dark square Bishop involved
into the game and castle on the Kings
side or he could always now move his
queen and castle on the Queen side still
undecided which way he's going to go
White's now going to play Knight to a3
as we talked about before eying down on
this pawn on c4 getting ready to gain
back that material as we talked about
that
Kasparov lost early on to the game
blacks now going to capture here on d4
but again this Center control is not
going to be lasted for very long why
it's going to play Knight takes on c4
gaining back some of that material and
blacks now going to play Bishop to c5
developing another piece getting ready
to castle on the King side more than
likely and
also defending this pawn here on d4 from
here Kasparov plays Queen to b3 eyeing
down on this pawn on b7 now it's very
hard for black to hold on to this pawn
on b7 now Black is up in material so he
can give this material back if you
wanted to castle on the King side which
he does choose to do he does need to
make sure that he can't move this pawn
forward anymore white does have two
attackers he does have his Knight hear
attacking this knight on c6 also don't
forget about this bishop here on g2
controlling this long diagonal of the
light square so obviously a mistake
would be to bring the pawn to b6 or
anything the Queen can't come to b6 to
try to help that out he would just get
gobbled up by the knight
now if the rook came over to b8 trying
to hone down and control this pawn on b7
white actually has a nice move he can
bring his bishop over to f4 and then
this Knight anytime he wanted to he can
move take a piece and have a discovered
attack against the rook there on b8 so
in this situation black just decided
that it would be easier just to give
that material back if white wanted to go
ahead and bring the Queen up in the
black's house over here instead black
decides to go ahead and cancel on the
King side give that material back and he
does have this King side safety team
continue to try to control the center of
the board so white actually does have a
few options here he could have always
brought in his Bishop over to g5 if he
wanted to pinning down this night here
on f6 to the Queen or he could you know
go ahead and bring his Queen - b7 if he
wanted to um I think it you know in this
situation it's probably easier to bring
his Bishop to g5 but again as we talked
about conspired is really just trying to
be as aggressive as he possible trying
to get all up in the grill of deep blue
and so that's exactly the does he plays
Queen to b7 really trying to be as
ggressive as possible with his Queen
right here black decides now to go ahead
and start gobbling up some of the
material in the center of the board and
he plays Knight takes on e5 and why it's
going to take right back with Knight to
e5 blacks now go to plate
rook over to v8 does want to kick this
Queen off it is kind of a nuisance right
here and the Queen's just going to come
right back to f3 kind of a nice square
still allows this long light square
diagonal to be dominated by this Queen
and the bishop and this pawn here on b2
is not going anywhere so very very nice
from wise you can kind of see both sides
you know white now has this dark square
bishop he needs to get involved into the
game develop that before he's done with
his development for the most part though
black is done in his development he does
need to get his major piece out involved
into the game but the rest of his minor
pieces are out in the middle of the
board so this pawn right here for d4 is
kind of a strong point it's very very
close to getting promoted but as you can
see it is taking the resources of this
dark square bishop here on c5 trying to
defend this pawn so this dark square
bishop would actually be like to be
involved into the game and he's not
really doing a whole lot it's kind of
playing defense right now because part
of the rest of the game is going to be
playing aggressive blacks going to be
playing more of the defensive so just
keep that in mind
from here black's going to play Bishop
to d6 again attacking this night here on
e5 and White's going to play a knight to
c6 now white does have a few options
keep in mind that he could if he wanted
to just kick his knight up and take the
bishop here on d7 now after the Queen
comes here takes on d7 white can always
come to d3 centralized square you always
want your your Queen's your bishops to
be central squares so they can hit as
many squares as possible the more moves
your pieces have at their disposal the
more powerful they're going to be so
definitely definitely a possibility for
white but as far I've actually wanted to
be a little bit more aggressive so
instead he brought his knight and he
played it Knight to c6 now why is this a
little bit different because now after
the exchange here obviously this needs
to be taken because white is threatening
both this rook here on b8 and this Queen
here on d8 but after the exchange when
white recaptures
she now has his queen on c6 so even in
your own games when you're looking at it
you think you know what it's going to be
a great exchange for me to exchange my
knight for their Bishop whatever you
want to do kind of look at different
variations because one variation your
Queen may be in one place where the
other variation your Queen could end up
on c6 so in this variation because
probably wanted his Queen to be a lot
more active definitely controlling these
long light squares and the center of the
board so that's exactly how he played
black is now going to respond with pawn
to e5 again this dark square bishop was
kind of the main defender of this pawn
here on d4 so definitely needs to make
sure that this pawn is now doing
something in defending this pawn here on
d4 so definitely good job by deep blue
making sure that his minor pieces are
not just sitting there in the middle the
board just defending the pawns here so
White's going to play rook over to b1
definitely wants to get ready for his
dark square Bishop to get involved into
the game if he were to go right away
this pawn here on b2 with left hanging
so he definitely needs to get his dark
squared Bishop involved into the game
so that's kind of why you see this rook
over to b1 from here the works going to
come down to b6 attacking this Queen on
c6 making sure they doesn't kind of stay
in unwanted territory you never want
your Queen in your own territory because
he can do so much damage you really have
to worry about him of what he can do
because he can pretty much attack all of
your pieces in one or two move so from
here the Queen's just going to come back
to a4 kind of a safe zone from white and
then the Queen's going to come over to
b8 trying to eye down on this pawn on b2
s we talked about there's only one
defender from white here on b1 so
loading up on this B file again anytime
you have an open file or semi open file
you definitely want your major pieces
your rooks and your queens on that file
because they have a lot of room to work
with and they definitely work well
together
from here White's going to bring his
bishop over to g5 again as we talked
about wanted to get this rook here and
then swing the bishop over to g5 now
Kasparov definitely had a few options if
you wanted to he could have tried to
defend more on this pawn on b3
but instead he decided that it would be
more beneficial to give double pawns
here on the F file in exchange for
giving up a pawn on the queenside that
he really was not you know trying to
hold on to that much so from here black
decided to go ahead and play Bishop to
e7 does not want to right away you know
exchange and get these double pawns
later on eeeh actually eventually does
but right away he plays Bishop to e7
kind of a waiting move to see what
White's going to do now why decides to
play pawn to b4 which is an interesting
move he did have a few other options you
know we could always play pawn to b3 if
he wanted to you know he could have
always taken here on f6 and then left
this dark squared Bishop here on f6 you
know both sides are now opposite colored
bishops but kind of just defending this
pawn here on e5 definitely an option but
instead kind of plays the more
aggressive in place pawn to b4 now here
it's pretty interesting because both
sides right now if you actually run it
through an engine or kind of study the
game it's kind of even right now black
has equalized both sides you don't have
a lot of different things they can do
but white doesn't have a huge advantage
right here so black does have a few
options he could take with his rook here
on b4 this is actually the move that I
prefer
I feel like this attacks the Queen here
on a4 makes white kind of react to what
black is doing but instead black decides
to take with his Bishop here on b4 and I
feel like this may have been a slide
inaccuracy I feel like the blue could
have probably found a better move but
you know all things considering you know
deep blue is pretty much dominating this
b4 square Kasab decides you know what
since this bishops no longer defending
I'm going to go ahead and give black
double pawns here on the F file so after
the pawn takes here on f6 then White's
going to play Queen to d7 now this Queen
here is not only attacking the pawn on
a7 it's also attacking the pawn here on
f7 and
he wants to he can always come over to
g4 and check the King here and put a lot
of pressure on this King on g8 so a lot
of different options black really has to
you know stay aware of what this Queen
is doing and black plays Queen to see a
making sure that the Queen has not come
over to g4 for check now I'll say V if
you kind of look at this a black is up
in material now so anytime you're up in
material it's actually better to trade
down the more you can trade down the
more you can exploit your weakness that
excuse me your strength that you have in
your material advantage so you know if
black could he would just give up all
you know his pieces and pawns and be
left a king and upon verse his perhaps
King so I'm in this situation
Kasparov definitely does not want to
give up his Queen he does not want to
trade down the material but he instead
he wants to start being a lot more
tactical with his move so he plays queen
takes on a seven again gaining that
material back that he lost from here
blacks can continue and play rook to b8
kind of bringing this rook back here so
he's on line with the rest of his major
pieces right here the Queen's are going
to come back to a4 was kind of in a
vulnerable position here on a7 kind of
blocked off with this pawn on d4
definitely wants to make sure these out
of this pawn structure and if he needs
to retreat by any way shape or form he
can come back to b3 c2 Rd one right here
it's definitely a nice little move right
here and then blacks going to play
Bishop to c3 if you watched any of my
other videos I always talk about outpost
rot it's very important to find a great
outpost for a knight whether it's a
bishop in this particular case only a
major piece a rook or a queen can kick
this bishop off here on c3 obviously
both sides have opposite colored bishops
which we'll get into later in the
endgame so this is going to be a very
very important square for black because
white pretty much has no option to get
this off unless you want to exchange one
of his major pieces which Jericho's barb
is just not going to do so from here why
decides to go ahead and exchange rooks
here on b8 after the exchange White's
now going to centralize his Bishop to e4
now this is very important anytime you
have a bishop you always want to
centralize it Thoth
has more squares that they can hit now
while this Bishop Iran g2 is pretty much
controlling this long light square
diagonal once he comes to e4 he has a
lot more squares that he can control now
this goes the same for a bishop as it
does for a queen as a rook that's why I
always preach you know if it workers on
the open file or semi open file it's a
lot more powerful because it can move a
lot early on in the game before rook is
actually developed or you castle on one
side of the board your rooks not doing a
whole lot so it doesn't matter even if
you're up you know four or five points
and material if you have a rook that's
sitting there not doing anything you
might as well count that is an even game
because if a piece isn't doing anything
you it really doesn't matter so I
definitely want to make your pieces more
powerful and you do that by giving them
more opportunity in more room to control
on the board so definitely a nice move
by garry kasparov to control the center
of the board with his light square
bishop now the queen is going to come to
c7 here kind of a centralizing square
here if he wants to we can always bring
his rook involved into the game does
want to make sure that he's protecting
this pawn here on f7 also allowing him
to kind of hone down on this c3 square
definitely gives him a lot more options
here on c7 than it does on b8 now the
Queen's going to come over to a6
attacking this pawn here on f6 really
forcing blacks to protect this and also
he can always bring his Queen back to d3
which we'll see here in a minute
allowing him to have a double attack
here on this pawn on h7 so from here as
we've talked about the King's going to
come down to g7 does need to protect
this pawn here on f6 and why it's going
to continue with his plan and bring his
Queen over to d3 putting a double attack
on this pawn here on 87 black does have
a few options here you can always bring
his pawn to h6 if he doesn't want to
give this up again it's going to fall if
he doesn't move because he does have a
queen here on d3 and a bishop Brioni for
both the tackiness or he could if you
wanted to bring his rook over to the 8th
he can't bring it over to a8 because
again white is controlling this long
light square diagonal but it could
always bring over to be eight and then
swing it down to b2 and then try to
attack and gain back this pawn here on
a2 that he's
lose over there on h7 he does opt for
the ladder and this move he actually
brings his rook over to b8 sacrifices
his pawn here on 87 and he's going to
come back and get that pawn right back
here on a 2 so gives that material up on
h7 and then he swings down his rook to
b2 now White's just going to bring back
his Bishop to e4 again nice central
square for the bishop here on e4 and
then the rook is going to swing over and
capture here on a 2 notice that both
sides are equal in material both sides
have four pawns a bishop a rook and a
queen here now as you can see both sides
have opposite color bishops so we'll go
ahead and get into this it kind of plays
towards the endgame but if you have
opposite colored bishops you want your
own pawns on the same color as your
bishop now typically you don't want to
block off your your bishop with your own
pawns but you want to put your pawns on
the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop show if black had a choice he
could move all of his pawns on dark
squares and he does that so that this
Bishop pretty much loses a lot of this
effectiveness now granted this light
square bishop is still controlling a lot
of the light squares but if the major
piece is that these rooks
and these Queens were to come off the
board this Bishop is pretty much just
negating some of the moves from the King
because the the pawns are no longer
being attacked so if you can if you can
anyway force it you want your opponent's
pawns to be on the same color as your
Bishop and you want your pawns to be on
the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop so just keep that in mind while
you are playing going into an in game
with different colored bishops
definitely lot of strategy as far as
where your pawns should be on the board
now from here Kasparov starts to push
now he's already taking this pawn here
on 8 7 which pretty much frees up this G
file and this H file and the pawn here
on f7 is actually going to make it a
little bit harder for black to swing
over his pieces and get involved into
the defense so why it's going to take
advantage of that and start to push up
the board is going to play pawn to h4
black is going to play Queen to c8 again
he needs to maneuver over here as fast
as possible
and the queen is going to come over here
to f3 again this putt this Bishop here
on e4 is a great central square pretty
much controlling a lot of the board a
lot of the light squares on the board as
you can see he's controlling a lot more
squares than this Bishop here on c3 this
this dark square bishop although it is
on a great outpost is not as central as
this Bishop on e4
so this bishop is a much better Bishop
as far as his control as far as how he
can move around on the board definitely
going to be much harder to deal with
then this Bishop here on c3 if we kind
of look at the Kings you can see White
has a much much safer King than the
black King right here there's no pawns
in front of the King it's going to be a
lot easier for Kasparov to chase this
King around then it's going to be for
blacks to come over and change this King
around so King safety is so huge this is
why earlier in the game white really
wanted to even give up a pawn at one
point to open up this G file and then go
ahead and move maneuver his pieces over
to take this pawn on h7 now from here
blacks going to play rook to a1 trying
to open up the door so we can start to
attack the king here rooks are going to
go ahead and come over to a1 no really
other way for him to hold on to that so
he's going to go ahead and exchange his
rooks here the bishops can I come over
to a1 it's not really doing a whole lot
on a once definitely gonna need to come
back over involved into the game the
Queen's not going to come to h5
definitely very aggressive move as you
can see this LightSquared bishop here on
e4 and this Queen on h5 they actually
work really really well together and
you're going to see that throughout the
rest of the game where you can see this
Queen on c8 and this Bishop on a1 they
haven't done anything in tandem the
entire game together so any time you're
playing you always want your pieces to
work together very very important
especially as you get involved into the
endgame so the Queen's going to come
over here to h8 now black would actually
want to exchange pieces off and why is
that because as we talked about Black
has a dark square bishop and he has all
of his pawns on dark squares and that's
exactly what
you want when you have opposite bishops
opposite colored bishops going into the
endgame typically you don't want to
block off your own Bishop but in this
case knowing that your opponent has a
LightSquared Bishop it would be
completely fine for black to exchange
Queens off knowing that his pawns are
going to be really really hard to attack
because his opponent has a LightSquared
Bishop involved into the game but as we
can see
Kasparov knows this and he knows his
Queen in his position is a lot more
aggressive and so he is not going to
exchange because he wants to continue
attacking the King is kind of out in the
middle on g7 so he's going to refuse
that and continue with his assault so
Queen to g4 check and the king is going
to come over to f8 now keep in mind this
is a timed game so after they reach 40
moves they get additional time on the
clock so we do see some of the moves
repeat they do make sure that they don't
have a three-fold repetition any time
you have a same position on the board
three times it's a draw
so he definitely does not want to have
that but there are times where you will
make the same move and have a two-fold
repetition just so you can kind of get
closer to that that 40 move marking get
additional time on the game so that's
kind of what we're going to see here the
Queen is going to come to c8 the Kings
are going to come back to g7 and the
Queen is going to come back to g4 and
now the King is going to come over to f8
and now obviously you can see the moves
are going to change a little bit the
bishops going to come over to d5 now the
King is going to come to e7 now Bishop
c6 the King back and the bishops going
to come back to d5 so that's kind of all
the repetition that we're going to see
we have two of the two fold repetitions
but no more than that because conspired
definitely does not want to draw this
game he's already down 1-0 in the series
he wants to make sure when he's playing
the white pieces that he's going to come
out on top with a 1 ok now if we just
kind of look at this position right here
you can see that blacks pieces are not
working together at all they're pretty
much separated by all these pawns that
mil the Queen here on h8 is pretty much
as far away from this King as possible
this bishop
pretty much can do a whole lot of
nothing it's going to take him a couple
moves just not to be blocked off by his
own pawns well if you look at White's
position although he does have the same
amount of material he's going to be a
lot more likely to be able to attack
very quickly he'd always bring his queen
over to c8 if he wants you to attack you
know his bishop here on d5 is very very
centralized always going to be putting
pressure on this pawn on f7 so it's
going to be very very easy for conspire
to attack we're deep blues pretty much
just trying to hold on and get a draw
out of this game it's pretty much no way
that the blue can win this game just try
and hold on for a draw why it's going to
continue after black plays to King the
e7 White's going to come over to f3
getting ready again he always wants to
make sure that his bishop and his queen
are working together here now the
bishops going to come back to c3 try to
centralize it as much as you can pretty
much going to hold on to this long dark
squared pawn chain with the bishop here
but again this dark square bishop really
not doing a whole lot in the game
especially as more pieces start to fall
off the board really just not doing a
whole lot in the game it would actually
be better if the pawn and the outpost
was here on d4 controlling more of the
board but alas it is not it is here on
c3 White's now going to play Bishop to
see board getting ready for his Queen to
get involved into the game the Queen now
is going to come over to c8 trying to
thwart some of this attack obviously the
Queen can't come to c6 here or b7 as you
may have wanted to also attacking this
Bishop here on c4 the queen is going to
come to d5 though as you can see white
now has a much much stronger attack than
black does and also white has kind of
blocked off any you know working
together that black may have had for his
pieces now from here until the end this
is kind of what we you know it's the
endgame we've kind of been going into
the endgame for the rest of it I'm going
to kind of be going through the moves a
little quicker just because it's all
pinpoint precision but what I really
enjoy about this is because prov really
plays like a computer he plays you know
precise pretty much all this
was just trying to gain a little bit of
advantage on every single move and over
time he kind of adds up and allows
himself to to gain an extra pawn here a
few moves later you know add a few small
advantages and gain another pawn here in
the end he's just up too much material
for black to deal with now if you kind
of look at it black really doesn't make
any blaring obvious dumb moves it is a
computer it is a supercomputer there's
not going to be anything crazy out of
the ordinary where he just sacks a piece
for no reason or doesn't anything too
crazy but white displays so precise that
it's really hard for black to do much
you just does not have the resources to
hold on to the attack that as far as
going to unleash on this computer so
just keep that in mind we do have Queen
to e6 this excuse me the Queen's are
going to come over to b5 d7 going to
check the king going to block trying to
exchange obviously Kasparov has no
intention on exchanging Queen to a7
Queen to d7 here and then Queen over to
a8 pretty much not really worried about
anything black can do here
Queen is going to come c7 back down to
a3 getting ready for an attack trying to
get this pawn here on f7 Queen's going
to come to d6 now coming back over to a2
putting a lot of pressure on this pawn
on f7 now the pawn is going to come to
f5 again you can start to see you Kappa
that the wheels come off for black here
starting to put his pawns on the light
squares definitely not something you
want to do obviously also getting ready
to give up this pawn here on f7 so
White's going to take advantage come in
and take that pawn there on f7 pawn is
now going to come forward does want to
make sure that he is you know protecting
this so all of his pieces and pawns are
now protected in one way shape or form
you do have this little do and you also
have this little duo the only weakness
is this pawn back here on f5 that does
need some defense now that the bishops
going to come back over to to h5 the
Queen's are going to come to f6
defending this pawn as we talked
two out here on f5 the queen is not
going to come to a3 now we really start
more of the attack from Kasparov he is
up one pawn and material now he's just
going to continue his assault it really
arranged his pieces exactly where he
needs to so King back to d7 Queen a7 d8
Queen to b7 d 7 Bishop get the bishop
involved into the game he was kind of
just hanging out until he was ready to
come in and attack now it's a check the
King's going to come back to e7 bishops
now going to come back to b5 bishops
going to come to d2 the Queen comes to
c7 and he comes back to f8 now obviously
he wants to make sure that he doesn't do
anything crazy you know if he would have
come down to e6 definitely would have
been a huge mistake
you know white could easily just come in
and play
you know Queen to d7 definitely going to
be a lot harder for black to do anything
here instead he decided to go ahead and
bring his King back to f/8 and Bishop to
c4 again continuing the attack getting
ready to you know pretty much dominate
this King here on f8 bishops coming back
he's just kind of going back and forth
not doing a whole lot you can kind of
see blacks just kind of waiting to get
dominated by Kasparov
computers don't only have a lot of
patience back in the day so the king is
going to come to g2 Bishop now comes
back to e 1 trying to attack this pawn
but it really doesn't do a whole lot
King is going to come back to F 1 we
have Bishop to c3 and then we kind of
have a push from Kasparov so pushing
forward with f4 and then after the take
this is all pissant I know a lot of you
are like oh that's not a real move it
actually is a real move anytime you move
two spaces with your pawn a pawn right
next to it on the 4th rank or obviously
on the other side it would be the 5th
rank but the the pawn can actually
capture just like that
so this pawn is gone and Kasparov is
going to recapture with this pawn and
now the bishop is going to come to d2
and now the pawn is going to come to f4
trying to have this pawn
getting ready to move forward on the
kingside of black here so the king is
going to come over to EA t' again
there's not a whole lot of great moves
this pawn here on d4 is really blocking
any you know aggression that black would
like to have with this queen
y is just going to play c8 getting ready
for an attack and then the King comes
down getting the Queen involved more
into the game after the King moves
giving this Bishop trying to attack
trying to get this pawn here on f5 again
if he can go up to pawns in material
that's pretty much going to be gg from
here the bishops going to come over to
III trying to control this pawn here on
d4 doesn't want this pawn to fall as
well the Queen's just going to come over
to f5 now white is up two pawns of
material white no longer cares about
exchanging pieces before Queen excuse me
black actually wanted to exchange it was
going to be good for him but in this
situation since White's up in material
he wants to go ahead and exchange down
he would be up to pawns to none if all
the equal pieces were taken off the
board but black knows it you know if he
were to exchange his Queens it would be
game over so he decides to decline and
then a few moves later pretty much just
setting up the inevitable few moves
later he is forced to take this Queen
here on d7 so attacking the King there's
no other way to hold on to the Queen
he's forced to capture recapture here on
d7 after the King comes to sin c7 Bishop
comes down to b5 and the computer was
forced to resign
he's down to pawns in material to
Kasparov one of the greatest players of
all time and there's just no way for him
to do anything else in the game so
definitely a fantastic game from
Kasparov especially when we get into the
in game his precision just to find those
tiny nuances to improve his position at
all times
definitely definitely fun to watch so
hopefully you guys enjoyed Game two
we're now tied up in the series one to
one because bob has done an excellent
job to tied up so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below I will see you guys in
the next video
thanks for watching